all right let's go to the phones and see
what's on people's minds let's start
with our caller from the 6:00 to 3:00
area code 6 2 3 go ahead I do I'm
wondering every time Sarah Huckabee
Sanders or anybody on the right Trump
you know anybody on the right but first
- it's the Dems fall when trying to pass
their legislation you're for example the
migrant children do people actually
believe them like they have all the
power they have that in the house to
send all the votes to do anything I'm
wondering do I have this wrong when you
say do people actually believe it do you
mean do they believe it when they say it
or do voters believe it when they hear
actually I'm not talking about like the
people with the cognitive dissonance or
you know the the base followers because
they're gonna fall them no matter where
I'm walking by um you know people in
general Jersey did he believe that
rhetoric or or do do this he pastor
lives because I don't see any any good
indication that people don't believe
that last night I just seen that
somebody still believes that there was
illegal voters in 2016 i watch right
well i mean i think it just depends it
because if you say in general versus so
you already said clearly like the
committed Trumpets do you believe that
everything is Obama or the Democrats
fault so if you take them out of it then
it's like some people do some people
don't I think the more important thing
is do enough people believe it such that
Republicans can win in the midterms and
then again in 2020 and I'm scared that
the answer is yes and too many people do
believe that it's either some vague
Democratic obstruction or something that
Obama did it or whatever that's
responsible for the fact that the not
everything is going right for the Trump
administration and a lot is going wrong
and I think it's something that I have
not yet found a way to fight against I
think the the path forward is voter
turnout is low enough that if people who
don't fall for the BS get out and vote
we can take control back but too many
people do believe
and as you mentioned some people still
believe three to five million
individuals voted illegally for Hillary
Clinton so I don't think you can fight
it on a person-by-person let me change
your mind basis you just have to get
more people out to vote yeah I fully
agree with you I've been trying to did I
activate activism myself but like it's
so crazy because like it's just facts
you just look at it and like they have
this and that and you know anything that
they want to do I just don't know how to
I just plainly put it down because they
just still don't understand I don't know
yeah they're not going to sadly they're
not going to I really appreciate the
call thanks very much